so in this crazy outcome that i could
have never foreseen
80 of the portfolio even though revenues
are down
are actually ahead of free cash flow
forecasts you
cannot [ __ ] people you can't lie
to them you have to be totally
transparent whether that's good
bad or ugly you've got to tell the truth
kevin it's a real real real pleasure to
have you here um
first of all have you done through this
pandemic both on a personal level and
maybe
a macro kind of like a business level
you know because this pandemic has
created a lot of
you know winners and a lot of losers
it's been very all over the place
you have a vast portfolio you know how
are you
and then karma how is your business
world well
you know gary that is the question for
everybody in america today and you're
right there are winners and losers but
you know personally i'm adjusting just
like you are to living the world in a
digital way just
every day i communicate as we are right
now and
all of my companies i have over 50
portfolio companies now
have gone through this incredible
transition to what i call the digital
pivot
america 2.0 the ones that have survived
um you know first of all we've we've
gone through this
seven months now have been able to tell
a story online
shift to direct to consumer sales become
very proficient
at logistics and have been able to just
take away what they
lost from retail sales and sold it
direct to customers so in this crazy
outcome that i could have never foreseen
80 of the portfolio even though revenues
are down
are actually ahead of free cash flow
forecasts why
because they've gone from just doing 10
direct to consumer
to doing 40 to 50 direct to consumer at
almost 100
gross margin and they've saved their
companies now the ones in travel the
ones in entertainment the movie theater
businesses
uh the weddings those those the live
event stuff
i'm sorry they're going to zero and
that's 20 of my portfolio but 80
that's fantastic they're going to make
it so let's frame up the question that
this whole show is going to be about and
we have an incredible lineup starting
with you
where where is the customer's attention
how do you synthesize that question and
what is the answer well never in
our lives gary have we had the
opportunity to have such a captive
customer
they are sitting at home just like you
and i are they are looking to be
entertained
communicated with they are willing and
able to
purchase products and services but they
want it done conveniently and delivered
directly to them
they are not going to go get it anymore
this is the
digitization of america in a very fast
way
and what i've learned and this is really
binary
i used to have this joke gary i used to
tell people what career should you have
and i'd say well there's three careers
if you're going to go to college
and invest in yourself engineering
engineering
and engineering but now you know who i'm
hiring
story writers videographers
photographers
editors i'm i'm having to compete all
around the world to hire some people in
israel in italy and france to cut video
because all of my companies are telling
stories on their websites
and so we have now empowered a whole new
generation of artists who are doing
phenomenally well
that i would have never guessed
storytelling direct communications with
your customer
compelling them to watch that 1920 39 49
second video
that communicates what your product or
service is is what the successful
companies are doing
and we are spending millions of dollars
doing this digital pivot
obviously because of dragon's den and
then shark tank you're you have a
personal brand
how of you the human because you're
talking you know it's yeah obviously
as you can imagine i'm listening to the
first five minutes of this conversation
i've been spending the last 11 years
building a communications death star
to do everything you just talked about
because i basically believed that the
internet was going to squeeze the middle
everything was going to be direct to
consumer whether that's ott or
e-commerce and that the ability to
storytell and run the arbitrage the
distributions
was actually the game so i like those
chess moves of how they played out to me
i'm curious because i'm sure a lot of
people who are watching are curious
right now
what about you yourself within social
media
have you in these nine months because
i'm sure you've been busy
helping mentoring like i'm sure you're
on constantly on
calls with entrepreneurs of these 50
plus businesses
but what about you and your own personal
brand have you picked up a platform
have you started to use linkedin from a
content standpoint
have you downloaded tick tock where are
you the man
you the shark you the people where do
you sit personally right now
with with social or content creation
whether first party
because you grab the phone and do it or
whether you live a little bit of the
game i play
drock ironically is here for the first
time in seven months have somebody
producing for you you the personal brand
what's the production around that if
anything you know gary you are the role
model for guys like me
you got it right you guessed it right
the middle did get squeezed out there's
no question
and i really got involved in social
about two and a half years ago and i
hired a team of producers editors
and storytellers to work within my own
production company larry productions
and what i learned and this is the
paramount maybe
maybe i'll give you credit for this
because certainly watching you
you cannot [ __ ] people you can't lie
to them
you have to be totally transparent
whether that's good
bad or ugly you got to tell the truth
that is what a personal brand is built
off
the minute it's almost like the analogy
i use and i teach this stuff now i'm
here in boston i do
i used to do lectures in person but now
i do them virtually at harvard and mit
and temple and notre dame and i talk
about this stuff
primarily the graduating course of
business students and engineers about
entrepreneurship
it's like dating you know when you fall
in love
and you meet somebody and you're just
empowered by that magic
moment and i draw this analogy all the
time you just
it's so wonderful and everybody should
fall in love with whoever it's going to
be
but then as time passes things change
and maybe
a year or two later you're thinking
about cheating
okay and you do now you have a decision
to make after you've done that
do you tell the truth to your
significant other or do you keep it a
secret
and here's why i bring it up for
business you're going to get caught
100 percent of the time when you cheat
you're going to get caught because you
didn't tell the truth
your significant other can never look at
you the same
again you've lost 50 percent of the
equity in that relationship forever it
may not break up
you may go on but it will never forever
the same
yeah and in business the first time you
lie to your customers your
constituencies your shareholders
you lose 50 of the equity forever better
to tell the truth and take the hit
and the ownership and transparency and
intent around the i'm sorry
the that such that's absolutely right
everything out of your mouth comma
there's also the half pregnant sorry
and there's the real sorry and i think
corporations
the standards in which people want from
companies is completely
completely impossible for most companies
they may be good at
the environment but they're bad at wages
they may like companies are
a convoluted animal just like people and
this thought
that you don't understand how to say
sorry when you're trying to fix
something
people would rather dance look over
there a bird instead of owning it
and to your point in that lack of
apology creates more damage sometimes
than even the event itself
yes and that's exactly it and i tell all
my ceos now
look do not lie to the customers don't
lie to your employees don't lie to me
don't lie to anybody your shareholders
even take the pain
take the hit admit the mistake you made
and you will build a relationship
particularly with customers
what we're learning online is if you
have a direct relationship with a
customer and you're honest with them
and you tell them hey the product's
going to be delayed or sorry you've got
a bad product will replace it will give
your money back whatever it is
that communication ends up being very
very valuable over time
those customers stay loyal we've learned
that a hundred fold in our companies now
and now we're in across the portfolio
we're now at 48
directive revenue to customer that's
magic gary
that's friggin magic because that's 100
gross margin business
one of the uh we've run out of time
we're going to move on
we really appreciate your time but one
of the fun topics in the chess game of
what you're talking about is channel
conflict
for the people that still rely on a lot
of business from retail
as retailers watching them go around
them and that is going to be interesting
battles
of the next decade of business if you
like that video wait do you see my next
one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe